Are true siks considered idol
worshippers? Can a Muslim man marry a
sick girl if they are considered idol or
fire
worshippers? If you have heard my talks
on sikism, sikism actually is
against the against that almighty god
taking aar. A true sick who follow the
scriptures believe there's one God and
they believe that almighty God has got
no image. He's all powerful. The concept
of
God in sikism is close to the concept of
God in Islam.
But the question is not that a Muslim
cannot only marry an idol worshipper. A
Muslim man or woman cannot marry a
non-Muslim man or woman. The Quran says
in surah bakar 2 verse number 221 that
let not a believing woman marry an
unbelieving man or an worshipper until
you believe a slave man who is a Muslim
is far
superior to a non-Muslim even if he
allows you he may be the most handsome
man in the world he may be the richest
man in the world but a believing man
who's a bonds man who's a slave man
Allah says is better than unbelieving
man even if he allows you may be most
transformed with the richest and the
verse continues that do not marry
unbelieving woman or a mushria. So the
two things ID worshipper or unbeliever
means those who don't believe in Islam
do not marry unbelieving woman or a mush
until they believe a believing woman a
muslima even if she's a bond woman she's
much better than the unbelieving woman
even if she allows you she may be a
beauty queen she may be the richest
woman in the world she may be a queen of
the richest country in the world but if
she's unbeliever a Muslim woman who a
slave woman is far superior than
unbelievable even if she allows you. So
based on this verse of the Quran, you
cannot marry a non-Muslim. So the sick
even if the true sick following, you
will not be denied worship. Can you
marry? No. You have to believe in the
last time and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. To marry the
person should be a Muslim. It's
compulsory. Should be a Muslim. And the
prophet said that when you marry when
you look for a life partner, you look
for four things. One is beauty, wealth,
nobility and virtue. Religion that is
dee and the most important of all is
virtue. It is seen. So unless the
non-Muslim accepts Islam, you cannot
marry a non-Muslim. of that humus.